[Music]
it's time for et's social study your
quick look at what the stars are posting
online nothing but net for Adam Levine
maroon 5 frontman sunken epic half-court
shot the caption who said the rain
stopped in California but if you thought
that was shocking how about this
before-and-after post from Josh Brolin
the actor shared this shocking
side-by-side comparing himself at his
thinnest and heaviest a difference of 73
pounds I have to get rid of the weight I
have to get rid of this look our Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman hinting that
former bond Pierce Brosnan will star in
Deadpool to the stars caused quite a
stir with this group shot but looks like
they aren't given up any deeds on this
hang just yet meanwhile Peta Murgatroyd
is wishing her best friend and fiance
Maksim Chmerkovskiy happy birthday
the Dancing with the Stars Pro praised
him for being a great father and quote
the light that makes my soul ignite
you're the textbook definition of my
true soulmate
I never believed in one until I met you
[Music]